the new position has been consistent
since the beginning of the crisis our
policy is to support a peaceful
negotiated and above all democratic
solution as in the case of Venezuela
only the Nicaraguan people can choose
their leaders and representative in a
free and fair election just ahead of the
visit by the European Parliament - in
Managua the Foreign Affairs Council
underlined its readiness to use out
political policy instruments to
contribute to a peaceful negotiated way
out of the crisis and to react to the
further deterioration of human rights at
the beginning of this year the
Nicaraguan government accepted to seek
and negotiated way out and signed two
agreements on the liberation of prison
ears and the reestablishment of
political freedoms but it is clear that
the government had failed to live up to
these commitments the European Union
stands within the Korean people and
recalls that repression needs to stop
and respect for the constitutional
rights of all Nicaraguans must be
reached a bleached including the right
to liberty and freedoms of expressions
record mo Hawaii can also solo low
nationalist Roca suffering to be honest
than being a yellow pills esta camera
Accio a circle caso their magic opens
una estudiante Belga arrest an aldose
mil de hecho por participer in manifesto
see only Pacifica controller viola Sonia
derechos humanos
committee da Perez Reming yo e se
encuentra del nuevo en prisión para ver
assist edo era mujer en well daddy
hombre de Santos de novo another
solidaridad cope of the Nicaragua
epidemic assalam ki ASEAN adidas su
notorious
the cause limit device approvers and
vistas contracts pawns Ava's platoon
lissandra suman's incorrigible to govern
the Nicaragua to Maruti I'll go in tear
no quarians acidic ax prank on traumas
loss on Pacifica director ambos nuestra
solidaridad con los dedos restore
tirado's los desaparecidos con todo el
pollo nicaragua si pero pusimos de los
Ticos a los hechos el acuerdo de
secession union europea centro America
Oh yen aplicación practica say
fundamenta en el comportamiento
democrático yo yo la résolution que
mañana save Otara tiene Barrios puntos
essencial A's impulse are una solución
democrática me Deonte say elecciones fee
ablaze LMP o de una delegation del
parlamento repeal nicaragua so we come
to the resolution on the situation of
human rights and democracy Nicaragua we
vote on paragraph 7 of the original text
in two parts the first part who's in
favor
who's against who abstains it is adopted
second part by roll call the vote is
open the vote is closed it is adopted
and the vote we vote on the resolution
as a whole by roll call please vote the
vote is open
the vault is closed and it is adopted